hey i'm jessica williams and i play
professor yolali hicks and i'm mess
mickelson and i play grindelwald i'm dan
fogler i play jacob kowalski and i'm
alison sudall and i play queenie
goldstein we are here from fantastic
beasts the secrets of dumbledore and we
are going to take a buzzfeed quiz to
find out which
fantastic beasts we are
[Music]
so first things first which combo of
hogwarts houses are you slither door
raven puff slither claw huffle door
slither puff and griffin club yeah
i just like the sound of slither claw
just the name of it
yeah let's go with some i think i'm more
of a huffle door so i'll do that i chose
a huffle door because i'm a hufflepuff
and a gryffindor lover not a fighter
although if i have to fight i can't say
that i love it but i can do it
i'm gonna pick ravenpuff i know that i'm
a ravenclaw actually no i'm gonna pick a
griff griffin claw i feel like i i could
be brave if the if things came pushed
into shove pick a fantastic beast to
have as a pet a phoenix a niffler a
bowtruckle a thunderbird
a thestral what's an alchemy alchemy
that's tricky what would you pick i i'm
picking a phoenix because i think
there's something really powerful about
um
rebirth and
like rising from the ashes and that that
cyclical thing and i think
that that would be really inspiring and
a good reminder to have around the house
and you only have to buy one
i'm gonna get a boat truck oh yeah i
mean that's a good idea because they
always come in handy yeah
if i ever lock myself in the bathroom or
something useful okay i'm in between a
phoenix and a thunderbird a thestral's
kind of like a goth choice and i'm into
it
i mean nifly's just handy yeah yeah if
you like shiny stuff yeah you've got to
have a difference and like stealing a
little bit
it does it's not you stealing
technically right it's the niffler yeah
right all right i'll go for a
thunderbird next question which hogwarts
class would interest you the most
potions history of magic charms muggle
studies
care of magical creatures or defense
against the dark arts
well i know about muggle stuff already
so
defense against the dark arts oh i would
definitely choose care of magical
creatures because that would just be fun
and you got to clean up after room
muggle studies
no
no not really yeah yeah
history of magic why would you want to
read the history about it if you're in
the midst of it right that's right
you're making chumps yeah okay i'm gonna
go i like that i'm gonna go for defense
against the dark arts because you know
somebody's gotta
save the world
which item will you always carry in your
suitcase a good book a water bottle a
pen a pack of gum a first aid kit and a
tube of lipstick chapstick chapstick
that's right i don't know why i said
this that's what you did
i mean in real life a good book but i
really want to have that chapstick thing
yeah absolutely good book i mean is
there water in the water bottle
i would i would assume so i think i'll
go with a water bottle just in case you
suddenly stranded on a desert island
yeah yeah what if i gotta
drink a book
well i can always get water somewhere
you can never get the chapstick from
anyone that's true i gotta have a
cheerbook that's true pick a
fallen character from the wizarding
world to bring back to life
leta lestrange irma dugar
ariana dumbledore
sirius black severus snape or dobby the
house elf wow
dobby
i cried so hard
yeah he's the one i cried the most about
dude
yeah oh bless
i'm choosing sirius everybody does love
dobby okay i'm gonna go with
sirius black though he was just kind of
a vibe yeah i agree i mean it's a tough
one might go for dubby yeah okay
which quote from fantastic beasts do you
relate to the most for the greater good
my philosophy is that worrying means you
suffer twice
imperfect understanding is often more
dangerous than ignorance
the disapproval of cowards is praise to
the brave
well there are no strange creatures only
blinking people
you never met a monster you couldn't
love i would say well there are no
strange creatures only blinkered people
my philosophy is that worrying means you
suffer twice just because it has special
meaning
but i i think that's a great philosophy
yeah wow these are like kind of yeah it
keeps deep i like them like philosophy
is that worrying means you suffer twice
i'm gonna do that too because i forgot
all of them already
lastly pick a wizarding world narrative
you'd make into a movie the marauders
the origins of voldemort the peverell
brothers the legacy of the deathly
hallows wow the other wizarding schools
around the world the story of harry
potter through draco malfoy's eyes the
founding members of hogwarts
[Music]
the marauders yeah i'm going to say the
other wizarding schools around the world
because i would like to see every
morning i'm going to go other wizarding
schools no question because i really
want to share this what about going
through dragon ball for his eyes yeah
that'd be fine it's fun
oh i'm nude
wait i was new too no
yeah how do you go both good news i
don't know wait a minute you got new
you're quirky and a wee bit introverted
but the few people who have the honor of
being your friend are some of the
luckiest people alive i'm queen of
goldstein wow
yeah okay queenie you're optimistic and
sonny this position lights up every room
you walk we're the nicest one huh yeah
definitely we both got queenie which i'm
really happy with we're all happy here i
feel good about that be sure to watch
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore
[Music]
you